oh man okay
so our hero bagel bite he's back
uh this time inside edition this is
gonna look by the way we
i i didn't know how deep the rabbit hole
went on this and i actually
this sucks i meant to play the inside
edition last night and
i with everything else going on it was
just hard
it's okay we got it he he man there's
just
miles of videos of this guy going to
people screaming at him on their front
like so this is inside edition
blow up at the bagel store everywhere i
go i get the same
smart with the biting lick a customer
just
loses it because he says women reject
him over his size
why is it okay for women to say oh
you're five feet on dating sites
you should be dead that's okay by the
way who says that you're here
but i love the lady and she's like but
who said that to you here which one are
bagels by the way no women say that on
day you know you know what you know who
started that meme right
right oh yeah that meme as a joke by the
way
most of the guys i know that share the
and they literally
have you seen some of the memes where
they call you like a five foot ten man
lit
oh yeah like that's the whole joke it's
like
it's whatever like yeah i actually see
the memes where
it's like six foot and above they have
the rock but it's like five eleven and
under it's like that's we man
yeah and then like oh man most of us are
an average of five ten five eleven and
that's hilarious stuff
it's very funny
hilarious i'm not a very tall man chris
but it's funny
but reaction by the way that chicken
that was very fresh her smirk is his
[ __ ] brightness
just look at this customer's bemused
reaction the crazy video took place here
at bagel boss in bayshore long island
he was degrading us as women that's not
right
the video exploded on social media with
21 million views
on twitter alone shut your mouth so
who's to be fair he wasn't degrading
women he was just having a meltdown
about how girls don't like him
so now i need to point something out in
this next scene
guys inside edition i'm going to give
them credit they com
they knew what they were doing this was
just to troll him they sent somebody to
interview oh
this was by the way this is why i wanted
to play leslie i know what you're about
to do
they sent someone interview him but not
only did they send somebody they didn't
send a reporter they sent a producer
why because they decided
who's the tallest chick we got here it
was a dick move but it was
very very is he spoke to inside edition
by the way this was probably would tower
over me
oh yeah no this is a topic wait they pat
she's in she's in flats
because they pan out and she's in
sneakers and they do it on
they should have done the heels right
they should have done the heels i would
have done the i would be like sweetheart
go get some good feel this one please
please
take some money out of petty cash and go
buy deals but buy whichever ones you
want
do you think that a bagel shop is really
the place to take also
she could get it let's be honest and
also they have her standing closer to
the camera
like they're using every little trick in
the book so she just looms over the
other part is
watch how she this something i picked up
when i saw it watch how she holds the
microphone it's like she's interviewing
a dog
so basically i'm very small that's what
it looks like she's like here you go
little man
watch what take out all of this anger
with all of these
strangers public innocent people why not
why not
what do you mean take it out and you're
acting like i committed mass shooting or
something that guy twice my size
that women love the bullies attacked me
okay
you stuck your finger in his chest and
told him to get the [ __ ] out of your
face
and you were acting like like you were
acting like a guy that i would have hit
yeah you know what i mean now look look
she's wearing flats
i just want everyone to see that she's
wearing flats she's not wearing heels
she's
she's still towering over this guy
is quickly done talking you know what i
don't really know offense i don't really
like you that much so this interview's
over
it turns out he's posted videos of other
nasty confrontations
about his height on his youtube channel
here he is at a convenience store
i come in here i bet you they got that
from my upload to get a coffee
still my favorite breakout star from
this whole series has been officer j
moore officer james good because he's
just
yeah what do you want from me i
yeah i mean if you want to technically
you can you know
yes right here ask me what is my height
in a bar
right in his neighborhood and you
threaten to punch a guy that's half your
size
now comes the most epic battle of all in
the bagel store
you want to step outside you want to and
then we know this by the way
when you say that right it it it it
is automatic that the person that
attacks you you can't go like he's a big
bully he jumped
he attacked like if i say you want to go
outside
that's that i'm hoping to get my hands
you're initiating the fight
the moment you say you want to go
outside that's the guy who's just
started the fight
it could be a lot of script but the
moment you go violence is going to be an
option will you partake
it's like challenging somebody to a duel
if you challenge somebody to a duel and
you die
they can't press murder charges you you
hey you you agree to this duel
tell me in your i mean i know you can
now i'm saying back in the day
what happened yesterday morning the same
thing that's happening all my life
people think they're better than you
because they're told on you you know
whatever
shirt yes he lives out of a van mike
what do you think has a big collection
of clothing
yeah i mean i lived out of my car for a
while i stilled more than one shirt
and uh i went in basically to uh
order a bagel well but to be fair he
gets all this clothes from those my
american life dolls
he just takes them and they're the same
one sometimes
sandwich and the indian woman who had
never helped me there before
didn't seem to understand the concept of
egg whites
so we have to so wait wait i haven't
heard this part
this greatest man i've ever met in my
life
where you're just a little ball of rage
look but i gotta
listen my life's pretty shitty too chris
you know sometimes i go to a place and i
go yeah just egg whites please and then
they bring me a full egg and
you know what i do i go
[Laughter]
you would have to really you would
really have to uh
be very v you really have to
inconvenience me like either i
completely hated a food or something
for the most part like if i go oh yeah
i'll take a salad with ranch and if they
bring like honey mustard i'll just eat
it like i'm not
i'm not gonna take it back you can't
even give him the benefit of the doubt
and chalk it up to like well maybe he
had a bad day because there's like 50
videos of him every meltdown so you're
like this is just
the way he is saying it about three
times and i verified because okay i
understand
this is okay fine then she's she's doing
this
with a mouth and looking at people and
smirking and laughing and i started to
feel like i was
being maligned or you know i was i have
a feeling that like 90
of the stuff's in your head man yeah i
have a feeling that she probably
was talking about somebody else and you
took it and your your head's always on a
swivel to see if someone's
[ __ ] making fun of the little guy i
mean i'd laugh at you
i was just i'm making it fair like i i
wouldn't like laugh in his face
but i'd probably go i'd probably stand
on my tippy toes next to him oh that's
mean
selfie
like i was a less of a person you know
well technically i mean
yeah you are less well when they when
they with their faces and they're
degrading you and stuff so finally i
took it and it took and i says miss i
says what are you laughing at i said i'm
a frequent here
so now they're acting like they didn't
do it which got me mad but i you know
then from that point on that's when the
people
jumped in and my whole life people feel
that they could attack me
they could um you know they but you're
the one
that said let's take this outside they
would jump me from behind
punch me i had a guy cut in front of me
years ago and and he pushed me when i
asked him i was next why
didn't say none he just hey chris hey
chris hey chris
hey chris i've had people do that to me
too
that's called life like you understand
that even if you're
even if you're not four foot two that
you're gonna spend your life being
challenged by people like that's of
course this this this grand
experiment of humanity is is it's
constant little mini
social contracts being executed at every
given moment
it's very it's very easy to you know
lose your [ __ ] sometimes sometimes you
don't sometimes you do i get you're a
tiny guy so you feel like
i'd be like you know what this guy needs
a gun
like a a revolver has to be revolver
yeah nice gun
i just like open carry it i think if he
had a gun he would feel a little better
about himself he'd have a little more
confidence
right and then i don't think he would
explode so or a bunch of people would
die in a bagel shop one of the i don't
know why he's so mad there's a lot of
upsides like if you have those little
mini races there are full reese's to you
you're saving money
that's true dude i mean imagine two
reese's cups
that would be a huge big dinner come on
you're doing good
it's going on a long time anyway so the
video basically
takes over from that but the guy the big
guy hit me
and uh cause you said let's take this
outside he beats me in his bagel shop
he hits me uh i fell down like this this
is actually
from yesterday when i hit the uh look
i'm pretty much deformed at this point
so i'm gonna be launching a series of
lawsuits against bagel
boss incorporated uh but i'll settle for
a couple free bagels
that's the only hurt i got really i was
really stunned i accidentally i went to
the woods yesterday i was taking
i bet you he's the most boring man of
life he starts making the rounds
on talk on talk shows like they're going
to have him play bit part or he'll show
up on snl
he's going to get his little 15 yes yeah
well it's him it's like seven and a half
because
it's you know his height um he's already
said that girls want to sleep with him
and stuff like that they don't
all a lot the the test determined that
that was a